buenas tardes en medio de estrictas
medidas de seguridad su última en los
últimos detalles de este funeral militar
que se realizará como mencionas en la
capilla san jorge del castillo de
windsor que está a mis espaldas como
puedes ver además a esta hora algunos
integrantes del público intentan
ingresar hasta las puertas del castillo
para dejar flores para honrar la memoria
del duque y también para enviar un
mensaje de fortaleza a la reina isabel
con quien el duque estuvo casada 73 años
y tuvieron cuatro hijos el de mañana
será un funeral bien diferente primero
por el deseo del duque será un evento
mucho más sencillo generalmente este
tipo de funerales tienen 800 asistentes
en el caso del funeral de la princesa
diana en 1997 asistieron 2.000 invitados
y millones de personas estuvieron afuera
de la abadía de westminster en este caso
no por las restricciones del cob y sólo
30 invitados la reina sus cuatro hijos
nietos y todos tendrán que tener
distancia social y usar
luisa muchísimas gracias